it could be ganked a lot so guys I don't
have to tell you playing a full game of
dota 2 can be a grueling experience and
half the time that game is already
decided before it even begins in the
draft that's right guys this week on
desktop we're taking a look at the most
insane off meta hero picks in
competitive dota 2 that actually worked
the most impressive thing is I did it
with the useless fish the useless fish
they won't miss lava as well as the off
meta or new hero picks like panga leer
or when heroes like acts and necrophos
were considered uncommon also the X at
ti2 and of course this video wouldn't be
complete without the perpetual black
shape of the dota 2 scene the heroes
that no matter the meta are always a
surprise I'm talking about meepo techies
and the pub star king Pudge between
noggin
no they pick it they prove the punch you
can see Dendi smiling right now oh he
wanted it bad and papi gave it to him
guys the heroes in this video might be
off meta but the score eSports a new
line of t-shirts like the one I'm
wearing now our hell up Oh Pete now you
wouldn't leave the fountain without a TP
don't leave this video without checking
out our online merch department a link
to that can be found pinned in the
comment section it's like people only do
things because they get paid and that's
just really sad now let's get on with
this video in earnest with some roll
swapping picks that have analysts doing
a double-take some male wait hang on
hold the phone check he's actually
playing bhatia yeah that's what yeah
they swap so some male is playing the
Earthshaker this is actually a Medan but
shake up even like a simple crippling
fear of good from false whale
pleasure he's throwing the fish you're
gonna block him quickly universe as the
over bubbles
should have enough damage and crack some
angle Sammael there's your blink Farah
strike into that first little apartment
sir male the totem damage finishes up
even the tool it'll begin on the
lifestealer they'll send the
Nightstalker up that's that brush you'll
simply going to work it on the back
lines dad's old Luke's a male controls
and perfectly sized every center hitting
perfectly bar burger as well as burning
as well they're all dropping down Martin
no one's ingest you ever when you throw
turn man Fisher they can move themselves
up catching a cure some males go triple
kill I think that's had to stay his
ground just because the dream call
listen al ain't done yet an extra bar is
right - they give it to him those Iowa
will actually take the corn from him but
ingr all pushed up to date he's 13 to 2
and I would say this is a stomp that
just really doesn't really show the dumb
this is a slam from eg I see what you
did there
Evil Geniuses seemed almost comfortable
on like any hero it's crazy and now they
go for more fling which I'm curious as
to where this go is because I'm waiting
man is this gonna be that off flame or
Flay yeah there it is the universe comb
for the offlane morphling well alright
do you say so what are you doing that's
that's not where you want to be buddy
you're dead female gets the kill the
University BT have seven point two five
seconds of single targets tongue hmm
sumail just runs at people and he
doesn't really give a damn what you
think even Zeus holds to get the kill
and also good vision at the same time
and now he bounces mid he's gonna try to
fight they're gonna find court but here
they roar MUP as well at 7.25 second
stun duration it is real it is a thing
it is something you need to worry about
really really good and Samuel is gonna
get except universe jumps in stuns up
the board for a pretty long time
and black takes a day Little Rock
there's the roar so he Kronos and just
doesn't do anything and wait to as yet
to use his death work he's gonna alright
it's a ticket sound immediately he drops
the dead port at universes like nope
you're adapted strike they're gonna get
a double kill for sumail with the zoo so
they get boba as well with a you ice
receiving that last hit and that is
gonna be game good call good call fanned
out the slot so VP hey hello this is
harking back to the days when power int
is used to one run that one revenge over
and over again and I'm wondering Illidan
is this your is this your hero is this
something that you've been practicing
and she is a squishy almost melee carry
person a G hero right here we're gonna
see it she's in death carry that's what
she is yeah don't even need another
strike if you're grouped up as five on
the top with defensive capabilities
you've got the sauce out front oh god
this is this is risky generals in Vince
but they see him they don't see what yes
they do that way he's dead right yeah
he's gone recovery comes in with a Luna
but still not fighting and he killed she
ripped apart and taken down another back
from DK well let's put it off that one
to show they retreats they kill off one
in the back end is tusk Falls but Ozzy
can you kill a militant I don't think so
state 21 might be able to do with his
bar strike on cooldown econ get in there
with a charge across then push shadow is
well son stop a couple of heads in is
all they need to finish more for the
brain SAP or people more level a bit
longer cuz elderness turned on but
they've got a full five-man team white
for to support in exchange an asset
collectivity of the wreath King more and
look at your guy it's juggernaut alright
these these trap well I mean this is a
into happening you called it alright is
I ma to take down one life
with the Shadow Realm they have the
secondary stun yep sore looking to move
into position they have the toss back
and everybody from liquid in trouble but
never mind
that's that's the the dazzle no grave
but it's okay poison to Jesus he's gonna
find that kill then forward Nisha he's
trying to stay on top of mine control as
well as miracle they're going for the
fear they do manage to find it who the
back in fact that Canada mo with the
toss and now it is gonna be literally a
good price then it kind of like liquid
we're gonna find their own path back as
curl he's being destroyed by this point
that he's won armor he's this physical
nuke has been annihilating him is off
you say yeah we zoom out clapping and
safelane razor
this is universe enchantress is this
slashers way this offlane untouchable
max stats enchantress I don't want to
say it is because it would actually be
amazing if they did that is he really
gonna do it it's gonna be the universe
Enchantress well let's see how this goes
down for eg get that solo kill first
blood in top lane important Lane base to
charge they're going in for a little bit
of trouble trying to turn around he's
got favorite company but it's not in
time but Bash from our bringing down the
shadow fiend now eg find ourselves will
get farther ahead terms of the kills at
least oh yeah that that damage da mean a
couple of us charge that's he could die
and now actually won't fit Miss America
the ballot boxes underneath essentially
they're gonna go
for this one keeping them under central
vision can't do it with the rain now
super get in charge of Maui's down with
the nether strike super does get you
revved up is gonna be as a live for the
time being what could he do in return
plug the others well try to get himself
away ice ice ice is there to try to help
with a party lost super my exercises
surrounded by boredom up to the EEG
walkin et response look for the TP I was
a bit of a hopeful one it's not gonna
pay off three heroes willing on the side
of Fiji and Ichi cleaning up there in
the regen jungle oh man they are just
getting rekt guys those were some 10k
MMR pics that frankly only the pros
could pull off but sometimes the hero
pick itself is the surprise now that's
the name I've not here are the best off
meta picks in competitive dota 2 hmm
let me look at the hero list what does
America want to play I'm trying to get
inside the head of America morphling
chugger notes in the pool banning
phantom lancer like umbrella is like
like miracle can pick anything girl
give me Ricky miracle they don't know
he's here he's bottom on Ricky for now
yep their girlfriends so he's potty
blocking DDC into the magic missle can
connect eh we'll follow up with the
impel sila what are you gonna do you're
gonna spin for the rune g8 is actually
going back for the room so Cora can get
the first blood on to DDC
guild all these pesky stuns in the
nullifier of the brood mother and so
much information the observer in century
is on the hill back where they fought
last time so it's just a jump in if you
kill off the juggernaut
does he find back into this fight they
could not push himself far enough up the
hill and they're taking on board
it is matumbo I see his mind control his
quarter everyone's that triple kill for
miracle he doesn't even have to walk
anymore
he just rides on the back and throws
daggers of people an old truck he'll for
miracle honesty Magnus has come back
alive stealing for Oh what this light
dealer terribly dinar quarter on the
same lineup you know KP said they've
been thing they're gonna do any crazy on
secret Matt said there would ask them to
the deck done something caught this is
this is very crazy they just trolling us
they go be truck yeah they just has to
be something like hi to your mess around
play like everyone talks about how
powerful reflexes it's not that powerful
the stuff oh you are dots
I don't think Yap sir is just gonna walk
in the lanes reflecting run away okay
this is not your typical
expectation of secret he does have
reflection one what expose Leon I feel
like Medusa kismet like him as the three
man reflections gonna fly out something
the cost to this to split up jobs is
like I got loads of all my cast and
Akaka staple gun in the go put nice
thumb fruitful photic a nice you get to
kill the car quick enough it look like
there might be out he's getting pretty
low that's a slow coming through choice
couple trees a car quick enough first
blood and fake you don't want to hang
around Eva these right-clicks do add up
quick look at the stun I get a second
kill yeah they got that alright
fantastic start busy for there that was
okay I guess there were flushing the
hole what I spotted big one is in Vista
good to see everyone here jump when a
puppy kind of kill my swing up no they
car that's a jump through the epicenters
big Kaka rape dad and look the lastly
doing nothing at the moment as you just
get shredded for free dead already in
the meantime Oogie you need to run
you've got the mount about TP out as
fast as you can
they have got this done though double
kill for a sand for dead on the Sun
movie but it might be 5 SC he's trying
to run away he's trying to turn her on a
yacht so there's a stun is like it's
okay we can keep this gun sun's coming
up cool down but we don't even need the
right-click secure that's a team white
and swatter but that is a nice hero to
see here and there's gonna be a sprint
let's get a fight damage with the crush
couldn't get it first the tip a chain
one second on cooldown
cross will hit our DK he can't luncheon
sup away from this that raids could get
a little bit coy so now we can latch but
there's this follow-up stuff
all he needs is this little bit of extra
space maybe if he finally gets a damage
healing item it could deal a hell of a
lot more they're gonna find each other
5v5 engagement well she comes in and
that bkb's gonna pump crystals up on him
Oh higher back into a bulb and the
follow-up stud miss DK be absolutely
impaled and super we'll go down to most
impressive thing is I did it with the
useless fish the useless fish they won't
miss lava well it's always cool to see
pros play new or uncommon heroes to
their full potential
but there's a special place in our
hearts for this next very short list of
heroes guys these are the heroes that no
captain in the right mind would draft
and yet these are the times they
actually want here's the best of me PO
techies and punch all right it's going
to be a razor that's going to admit he
could be ganked a lot
thank you honey you know I'm probably
not garbage oh my goodness ego blocks
you hate techies I do hate techies start
thinking about kind of work being late
downtown why they start con for body
blocking close enough smells get the
tape like before this tournament I asked
some dota 2 people to remove the hero or
nerf them
oh yeah we're aware of that yes yes cty
heroes in the game only he's having fun
a lot of actually runs into a line there
and did you have fun playing
of course he's super fun you meet some
team fire left onsens solomid Tonka is
yeah that's a good cool
[Music]
and then try and take a very very quick
bro shut the bleep phone c9 they're not
gonna give vici gaming the speech oh
what a perfect company vaccine sorry
TK but it's isolated Tyler who now let's
Eclipse go super coming in here anything
he's just gonna count the doom on silo
and tank this up the deal
a little bit
quatl show mrs. oo7 is running himself
and he's grabbing apart he does either
they're not going for the towers back
inside the diaper or ether one of the
team boss Charla Natalie
[Applause]
means that you're going to be able to
split the experience really evenly
between us right now oh they pick it
they threw the punch you can see them be
smiling right now
oh they wanted it bad and pumpy gave it
to him & tongfu is going to continue to
push they're not done neck still hasn't
even been used there's Oh back to the
base and now plumpy going to be caught
out King J reengaged upon weird little
skirmishes breaking out behind us our
good vacuum and they're gonna dust it as
well now bindi getting back involved in
front some sharing gonna be dismembered
it cleans up in the meantime King Jenny
trying to TP away behind the fight
shackle does not latch we actually just
saw the chin Pudge combo at the
international that happened
nubby he got him
this is what you call I cannot believe
that they actually did it again that
look to have slipped away from them and
very well guys that's all I got for you
for best of this week
now this video gave you any pocket
straps to pull out in your next over to
pub well let me know in the comments
section like the video subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
because that's what we call a YouTube
rampage thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]